Hace unos días me apareció en YouTube un
vídeo llamado Cómo logré generar 90 mil
dólares online sin inversión y sin
experiencia y este vídeo lograba Allison
y básicamente en este vídeo nos Explica
cómo ha conseguido generar más de 90 mil
dólares en menos de un año sin inversión
ni ningún tipo de experiencia y le
propuse aparecer en el canal para que
nos explique cómo lo ha hecho y cómo
otras personas también lo pueden hacer
para quien no conozca el negocio de
print En qué consiste exactamente
básicamente
existen proveedores
cuál sería el paso a paso para alguien
que esté viendo esto y que le llame la
atención que entienda que va a tener que
trabajar mucho para empezar a montar su
negocio
principal